I know what you are
say it out loud say it vampire right
light turns 10 only et is with rob
Kristen and the rest of the cast talking
about the milestone and the movie that
made them household names are you afraid
know what would you today 10 years later
here you are promoting this amazing
movie say to yourself walking onto that
set for the first time it's kind of the
whole rides me really great I mean that
since I am just been incredibly lucky in
my career in my life and yeah I'm
already appreciative everything it's
been a long time I don't know certain
memories you have will be close to you
forever and so that'll never be normal
to say that something was that long ago
and I feel that way about that too
I did not think it was gonna be the
success that it was
and frankly playing a vampire that
sparkles there's no fangs
I just felt not a hundred percent of
vampire hello I'm sorry I didn't get a
chance to introduce myself last week I'm
Edward Cullen Bela Robson was rocked by
scandal that broke them up in 2012 but
there's no bad blood these days your
favorite boss lady damsel that you've
ever had the pleasure of working with Oh
tons and I would like some real like
powerhouses I mean definitely me as one
of them obviously I like Kristin Scott
Thomas Newman Kristen Stewart cuz I
thought you guys just hung out the other
day Christmas dude you were gone yeah I
was out of town for a couple of days
personal reasons the movie is being
re-released with some special elements
to celebrate Catherine Hardwicke and I
went back to Portland Oregon a couple
months ago so we filmed it all it's
gonna be on the 10 year anniversary box
set of the new Twilight or the Twilight
film rerelease sorry Joseph is our
newest vegetarian it's a little
difficult for and get this Jackson
Ashley and Kristin aren't ruling out a
Ryu
yeah I'll call them up alright now I
don't remember I mean we all stay in
touch a bit yeah naturally well what do
you make of Rob Pattinson recently
saying that he's ready for a twilight
reunion well I think look at the end of
the day things are being rebooted a lot
things are being re-examined castes are
being brought together for reunions so
be one thing if we had the whole cast
together I I wouldn't ever turn it down
I think the secret is you know there's
people out there you know really wanting
it to happen we'll see I really wanted
to I think you got to talk to Stephanie
Meyer she might be the the holder of the
the lock and key there if Stephanie or
to write another novel would you read it
would you want them to bring it to life
on the big screen first of all I would
pre-order it and I would read it yeah
dad no I definitely would absolutely
read it I think you know her writings
really fun and it's again like I gave
way to kind of relive those those days
the Alice days and I'd be interested to
kind of see where she would go with it
and they all still have great memories
of the vampy flicks Bela and I are gonna
be great friends and I definitely miss
that I think I became this character for
so many years of my life and I think a
lot of times it was all encompassing to
have to kind of put that chapter away is
that it's a weird thing and it's I think
she was also a really fun character in a
play like a complete opposite of Mia
yeah I for the most part like I just had
to go to work and be happy and playful
and sassy and you know that kind of Alex
that everyone has grown to love so it's
you know it was sad to put her away calm
is a scene though that's got to be a
home run right
it was very fat I just remember playing
vampire baseball I think that's the most
vivid memory I have and freezing rain
and running around and laughing and like
just it was so much fun
looking back yeah it's just all goodness
and yeah the only thing is a lot of us
like Peter and I and Jackson
we broke a lot of rules contractually
just because we felt like we didn't have
to be on set so much so we got kind of
bored and like Jax and I would we'd hit
the slopes a little bit we'd go
snowboarding and Whistler
do you miss that chaos no not at all not
at all yeah it's really nice I've moved
around I don't have paparazzi stayed
quite out of the limelight I'm not
really going to so many events and just
working it's been really freeing it's
really cool you know to look back and
and think ten years ago this our first
movie came out
it was a crazy red carpet I lost my
voice on the red car because he was so
long there's my first red carpet doing
so many interviews it was fun though it
was it was crazy but you know what it
was it was passionate